If you're one of the millions of people who
saw Avengers: Infinity War on opening weekend,
chances are you've got some questions about
what you've just watched and what's going
to happen next.
But more than anything, you probably want
to know about that one moment no one saw coming.
You know the one...
The good news is if you're ready to dive into
the nitty gritty of the movie and its many
connections to the comics, there's no reason
to wait any longer.
Let's get to it.
Do we even need to say "spoilers ahead"?
"Ready?"
"Let's go."
As we see in Infinity War, Thanos forces Gamora
to take him to the Soul Stone after she's
forced to reveal its location on the planet
Vormir.
There, the pair find that the keeper of the
stone is our old pal the Red Skull, who seemed
to meet his demise when he was sucked into
the Tesseract itself, a.k.a.
The Space Stone, and then shot into outer
space in the first Captain America movie.
He might look a little different when he shows
up in Infinity War, of course, since Hugo
Weaving didn't return to play the character
and was instead portrayed by The Walking Dead's
Ross Marquand, but it's still definitely the
Skull.
So what's he doing all the way out on Vormir?
Red Skull explains that he was cast out by
the Space Stone and imprisoned on Vormir,
doomed to lead others to the Soul Stone without
ever being able to use it himself.
In the comics, of course, Red Skull's relationship
with the Infinity Stones isn't really a thing,
but he does have a lot of history with the
Cosmic Cube, an item with similar powers to
the MCU's Tesseract.
However, the Infinity Stones are not related
to the comics' Cosmic Cube.
Say that five times fast.
Red Skull is one of Captain America's most
frequent comic book foes.
And although the hero has vanquished him time
and time again, he uses the Cosmic Cube to
come back from the dead, transform into and
possess people, and travel through time.
But in the MCU, the Space Stone was his jam.
And now we know that he isn't even connected
to that anymore, now he just guards the Soul
Stone, the only one of the six Infinity Stones
that uses its owner, rather than letting its
owner use it.
So what's it all mean?
Why would we see the Red Skull in this scene
at all?
Well… it may be foreshadowing.
You know that there are a lot of people who
kick the bucket in the end, thanks to Thanos'
supreme snap.
Some of those people, including Spider-Man,
Doctor Strange, and Black Panther, are expected
to have more than just one stand-alone project
on the MCU film slate, so mourning those losses
seem premature, to say the least.
Meanwhile, the Soul Stone in the comics tends
to capture its wielder and contain the souls
of others within it, in a place called Soul
World.
So it's possible that the Red Skull wasn't
trapped on Vormir to guard the stone.
Instead, he may be one of the stone's prisoners.
After all, the Red Skull's been there for
decades.
He should be dead, but the Soul Stone has
kept him alive this whole time.
So maybe some of the other characters who
seemed to die in Infinity War have been kept
alive by the Soul Stone too...
This could potentially answer the question
of how some of the many superheroes who bit
the dust in the film could be brought back
in time for the fourth movie.
Could those who were snapped out of existence
all be residing in the Soul World now?
There are other ways the fourth Avengers film
could bring back those lost heroes, of course,
especially since the Time Stone was proven
to be able to do exactly that by Thanos himself.
But if the Russo brothers are looking to surprise
some folks with a more unexpected resurrection,
well, the Red Skull's guardianship of the
Soul Stone might've just laid the groundwork
for exactly that.
"Wow."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!